اسعد الله مساءكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض والتي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار وملفات السعوديه
والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه تنشر صورا لافرادها
تقول انها سجلت من داخل مدينه باكموت
وزير الدفاع البريطاني يؤكد في لقاء مع
العربيه على قوه وعمق علاقه بلاده مع
الرياض
وزير الخارجيه السعودي يدعو الى حل صراعات
والنزاعات الدوليه لمواجهه التحديات
العالميه
في الرابعه كذلك
مجموعه روشين تسلم اكثر من 30% من وحدات
المرحله الاولى لمشروعها سدره السكني شمال
الرياض
متوسط امطار يناير الماضي يسجل اعلى معدل
له في السعوديه منذ اكثر من اربعين عاما
حياكم الله نشرت مجموعه فاقنا مقطعا مصورا
لقواتها داخل مركز مدينه باخموت بعد قتال
عنيف مستمر منذ اسابيع وقال مؤسس المجموعه
الان في مركز مدينه باخموت
اكدت الرئاسه الروسيه الكرملين ان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يتلقى تقارير عن
التطورات في بريانسك حيث تسللت مجموعه
اوكرانيه وتمكنت من احتجاز رهائن بحسب
تقارير روسيه وقال المتحدث باسم الكرملين
ديميتري بيسكوف انما يحدث في بريانسسك
هجوم ارهابي واشار الى ان روسيا تتخذ
اجراءات سريعه للرد عليه واضاف بسكوب ان
بوتين الغزيرته المقرره الى اقليم
لمتابعه الوضع فيبريانسك وشارك ذلك الى ان
بوتين سيجتمع غدا بمجلس الامن الروسي
لمتابعه هذا الوضع
وفي كلمه الله وصف الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين الهجوم على منطقه كالحدوديه
بالارهابي اقل ان المسلحين اطلقوا النار
رغم علمهم بوجود مدنيين واطفال
اليوم نفذوا هجوما ارهابيا اخر نفذوا
جريمه اخرى على منطقه حدوديه وفتحوا النار
على مدنيين رغم رؤيتهم بان السياره مدنيه
ويجلس فيها مدنيون واطفاله هؤلاء الاشخاص
اخذوا على عتيقهم مهمه انتزاع ذاكرتنا
وتاريخنا وعاداتنا وحتى لغتنا
نشرت المجموعه التي نفذت الهجوم في مقاطعه
بريانسكا الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا نشرت مقطعا
مصورا لعناصرها داخل المقاطعه وهم يرفعون
شعار الجيش الاوكراني من جهه اقاله
المخابرات الاوكرانيه ان الهجوم نفذه
معارضون من الداخل ضد نظام بوتين ويريدون
القضاء عليه في حين قال مستشار الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه ميخائيل ان الهجوم مفبرك ومزيف
هذا وتبنت المجموعه التي اغتالت ابنه
المفكره الروسيه المقرب من الكرملين
الهجمات في بريانسك
من موسكو تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض ما الذي توفر من جديد من معلومات
حول هذا الهجوم الذي طال منطقه بريانس
الروسيه الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا حتى الان هل
من معلومات عن ضحايا عن مصابين حتى الان
بالفعل من ان الرئيس الروسي وصف هذا العمل
الارهابي ان المجموعه التخريبيه
الاوكرانيه والذي وصفها بالنادين الجدد
كانت استهدفت
مدنيين في منطقه بريانس طبعا وسائل
اعلاميه روسيه تحدثت عن ان هذه المجموعه
التي قد تتالف من 50 فرد قد تسللت الى
الاراضي الروسيه
وتفرقت الى مجموعتين كل مجموعه توجهت الى
قريه قريه وسوشاني القريتين التي وقعتها
بهما الحادث في طبعا كما تحدثت
نائبه العمده هناك بان المجموعه الارهابيه
قامت باطلاق النار على سياره مدنيه ادت
الى مقتل سائق واصابه طفل بينما تنقلت
وسائل الاعلاميه ولم يتم تاكيدها بشكل
رسمي عن امكانيه احتجاز نحو سته اشخاص في
مخزن طبعا كان هناك
عمل لرجال انفاذ القانون الروس في المنطقه
وكما تناقلت ايضا وكاله التي التاس التي
تحدثت نقلا عن شهود عيان هناك بان هؤلاء
المخربين قد خرجوا الان من الاراضي
الروسيه وغادروا وانا الوضع هناك هادئ
يعني هم يتحدثون بان هذه المجموعه دخلت
الى بريانسك نفذت هذا الهجوم ومن ثم عادت
مره اخرى الى الى الى الى اوكرانيا
صحيح تماما نايف ولكن هذا الحديث هو ليس
من مصدر رسمي هو حديث تناقلته وكاله تاس
الحكوميه نقلا عن شهود عيان بان الوضع في
المنطقه الان هناك هادئ وان هذه المجموعه
التخريبيه قد غادرت الاراضي الروسيه هناك
الرئيس بوتين ايضا هل عقد اي اجتماعات
امنيه للحديث عن هذا الموضوع لان هناك
اخبار خرجت بانه اجتمع مع الامن القومي او
الامن الفيدرالي الروسي للحديث التباحث
ايضا حول هذه المساله وقطع زياره الى
اقليم اخر في روسيا كانت مقرره اليوم
صحيحه الرئيس الروسي قطع زياره له كانت
مخطط لها اليوم او قام بعقد عبر رابط
الفيديو الاجتماع مع مجموعه من الشباب
ولكن طبعا هو كما تحدث الكريم اجتماع
الرئيس الروسي سيكون مع مجلس الامن الروسي
يوم غد وليس اليوم كما تناقلت ايضا بعد
وسائل الاعلام الروسيه وهو اجتماع ليس ليس
بالطارق بل الاجتماع دوري يقوم به الرئيس
الروسي اسبوعيا مع اعضاء مجلس الامن
الروسي ولكنه كما تحدث قطع زيارته المخطط
اليوم وهو يتابع عن كتب الوضع حول دخول
هذه المجموعه التخريبيه من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه الى الاراضي الروسيه نايف
اشكرك جزيلا الشكر من موسكو مراسله
العربيه على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
بالعوده مره اخرى الى باقمت ونشر مجموعه
باجنر الروسيه لمقطع مصور قالت انه من
داخل مركز
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
تتابع معنا منذ اسابيع او حتى اشهر هذه
المعركه في اليوم قوه باك نرشبه الرسميه
قالت بانها دخلت الى مركز المدينه نشرت
مقطع فيديو قالت ايضا بانه سجل من هناك هل
هذا صحيح ام انه استعراض ربما للقوه وان
المعارك لا زالت ضاريه حول هذه المدينه
وفي طوق ضخمه
مساء الخير نايف بالفعل المعارك ما زالت
مستمره وضاريه في مدينه باقمت المعارك
الاعنف بالفعل قوات باغنر منذ عده ايام
دخلت الى المدينه دخلت من جميع المحاور مع
عدا المحور الغربي دخلت من الشمال ومن
الجنوب وكذلك من الشرق وكنا نتحدث عن ان
القوات تدخل كيلومترين او كيلومترين ونصف
او ثلاثه كيلومترات من كل ناحيه وبقي لها
حسب التصريح الرسمي من المصدر هناك بان
اقل من كيلو مترين متبقي للقوات للوصول
الى مركز المدينه حتى اذا وصلت قوات باغنر
الى مركز المدينه فهذا لا يعني ان السيطره
اصبحت كامله على المدينه ما زالت القوات
الروسيه تحاول اكمال الطوق اكمال الطوق من
الناحيه الجنوبيه غربا ومن الناحيه
الشماليه غربا بعد سيطره قوات فاجنر على
بلده ياجدنا تقدمت نحو بل
بلده خروموفا يعني تبعد الان عده
كيلومترات عن قوات فاغنر وهي تقريبا في
المحور الغربي وهي التي تسبق بلده بلداسكا
الهدف هو اكمال الطوق ما زالت الامدادات
تصل الى القوات الاوكرانيه رغم التقدم
الروسي تقدم قوات فاجنر لكن نايف هذا
التقدم بطيء يتقدمون ببطء لكنهم يسيطرون
على مجمعات سكنيه ابنيه بناء تلو البناء
اذا لاحظنا المقاتلين الذين استعرضوا
بالفيديو والذي نشر على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي نشره مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر
ايفغينيا بروجين قال بان
الاشقياء ابناءنا او رجالنا الاشقياء يعني
يستعرضون وهم تقريبا او عمليا في وسط
المدينه لم يحدد انهم في وسط المدينه قال
تقريبا انهم وسط المدينه لابد من الاشاره
ايضا انهم كانوا يحملون معهم الات
من المعروف او التسميه هنا لقوات فاجنر هي
الاوركيسترا او الموسيقيين اذا تحدثوا بان
قوات باجنر تعزف في المنطقه الشماليه اي
انها تقاتل في تلك المنطقه وكانوا بالفعل
يستعرضون هي عمليات استعراضيه لكن هي
اشاره حقيقيه الى انهم يتقدمون ويسيطرون
على مناطق او اراضي ولو ببطء لكنهم
يتقدمون في هذا المحور
المؤسس او قائد قوات باجنا ريف غينيا يوم
امس قال بان القوات الاوكرانيه وصلتها
تعزيزات في هذا المحور والسيطره على باخمت
ليس بهذه السهوله ايضا قال يعني قالت
السلطات هنا سلطات دانيه بان رغم ان قوات
اوكرانيا خسرت ما نسبه 70% من مقاتليها
المتدربين الا انهم يضخون او يعني هناك
تعزيزات وامدادات للقوات التي تقاتل في
باقمت و هم مستميتون بالدفاع عن المدينه
ولا يريدون الانسحاب حتى الان اشكرك جزيل
الشكر من دانه العربيه رائد الاغبر على كل
هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
اعلن وزير الخارجيه الروسيه ان مجموعه
العشرين لن تصدر اعلانا مشتركا محملا
الغرب مسؤوليه ذلك وقال في مؤتمر صحفي ان
الغرب يتعامل بانتقائيه مع مواثيق الامم
المتحده ويسعى للسيطره على موارد الدول
الناميه ومصادره حق الشعوب في تحديد
مصيرهم واضاف لابروف ايضا ان الغرب رفض
رفصه قاطعا مشاركه روسيا في التحقيقات
بشان الهجمات على خطي نورتي ستريم
نبقى في مجموعه العشرين وفي نيودلهي شدد
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان على اهميه حل صراعات والتطورات
والتوترات السياسيه وذلك لمواجهه التحديات
العالميه مثل اضطرابات سلاسل الامداد
والتضخم كما اكد خلال كلمته في اجتماع
وزراء خارجيه مجموعه العشرين بان مواجهه
التغير المناخي تتطلب مواصله العمل
الجماعي وزير الخارجيه السعودي شدد كذلك
على ضروره الاستثمار في جميع مصادر الطاقه
بما في ذلك المصادر التقليديه
ثمنا وزير الدفاع البريطاني بنوالس في
مقابلته الخاصه مع العربيه عمق العلاقات
مع السعوديه واكد ان العلاقات مع دول
الخليج لها اهميه قصوى بالنسبه لبريطانيا
على كافه المستويات
كانت جيده للغايه بقيت كذلك على مدى عقود
حتى قبل ان يبدا التعاون بين بلدينا في
مجال الفضاء والدفاع انا امثل شركه تعمل
في مقاطعه الانتخابيه هي شركه سعوديه
مصنعه لافضل انواع الاشمره التي تباع في
السعوديه هي موجوده منذ ثلاثينيات القرن
الماضي العلاقه الثنائيه قويه وعميقه
للغايه ولمنطقه الخليج اهميه قصوى بالنسبه
للمملكه المتحده على كافه الصعود
الاستراتيجيه منها او الاقتصاديه هذا يخدم
رفاهنا وهو امر ايجابي لقد عقدت اجتماعي
الثالث مع الامير خالد بن سلمان والتقيته
من قبل في لندن وكذلك هنا في المملكه قبل
عامين
وحول زيارته الى السعوديه قال بنولسين
هناك شمعه وزير الدفاع السعوديه الامير
خالد بن سلمان عده قضايا من بينها اليمن
وايران واشاد برؤيه المملكه 2030 مؤكدا ان
بريطانيا مستعده لتقديم كافه اشكال الدعم
من اجل انجاحها
الهدف من زياره مواصله هذه العلاقه لان
العلاقات تعني الابقاء على الاتصال الدائم
بيننا ومناقشه القضايا اليوميه وكذلك بحث
الخطط بعيده المدى هو امر هام فانا اشغل
منصب وزير منذ فتره طويله واقامه علاقات
وثيقه ومناسبه مع نظراء يحدث بالفعل فارقا
الامير خالد صديق عزيز استطيع ان اتناول
معه كل القضايا وهذا ما حدث حيث بحثنا
قضايا اليمن وايران والقاعده الصناعيه
الطموحه في السعوديه فرؤيه المملكه 2030
مشروع غايه في الاهميه بالنسبه لنا نريد
ان تنجح هذه الرؤيه ومستعدون لتقديم كافه
اشكال الدعم من اجل انجاحها سواء تعلق
الامر بمجال الدفاع او اي قطاع اخر انضم
الينا من لندن مساعد رئيس تحرير صحيفه
الشرق الاوسط الصحفي زيد بن كمي سيد زيد
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض تابعت تصريحات من ولس والحديث
عن العلاقات السعوديه البريطانيه وبانها
علاقات قويه ومتينه هل وصلت برايك
بريطانيا اليوم لقناعه او تصور بضروره
تطوير وتعميق هذه العلاقه مع دول الخليج
خصوصا مع السعوديه ولماذا
مساء الخير اخي نايف مساء الخير للساده
والسيدات المشاهدين
حقيقه البريطانيا مهتمه بشكل كبير جدا مع
علاقتها مع السعوديه واحنا في اكثر واكثر
من حديث للمسؤولين في في المملكه المتحده
لانهم يعلمون
اهميه ايضا يعني ممتده تاريخيه ممتده
علاقه المملكه العربيه السعوديه مع
بريطانيا يعني طويله جدا من ايام تاسيس
الدوله السعوديه الاولى لكن احنا اتكلم
حاليا الان لما تاسس المجلس الشراكه في
حينما زار الامير محمد بن سلمان ولي العهد
البريطانيا في 2018 مجلس الشراكه بين
السعوديه وبريطانيا واعتقد الان هو صار في
اكثر من الاجتماع لدعم يعني العلاقات
وايضا لتسهيل
تسهيل ايضا يعني ما تم الاتفاق عليه او
متابعتها ايضا في خلال الاجتماعات السابقه
نحن نعرف انه مثلا بريطانيا يعني مهتمه
بشكل كبير جدا نكون على يعني رفع الميزان
التجاري بينها وبين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اضافه ان
لديها اهتمام ايضا كذلك في كثير من
القطاعات السعوديه فيما يخص ايضا رؤيه
عشرين ثلاثين ماذا عن عن الرؤى السياسيه
البلدين سيد زيدين يمكن ان تلتقي هذه
الرؤى اين يمكن ان
تختلف وكذلك هل اليوم العلاقات السعوديه
البريطانيه يمكن توصيفها بانها في حاله
افضل او في حاله يعني افضل مما كانت عليه
قبل اربع الى خمس سنوات
البريطانيه هي
في هناك يعني هناك رغبه شديده جدا من سواء
من جهه
البريطانيا لتقويه العلاقات في في شتى
المجالات حتى ايضا لو كانت هناك بعض
الخلافات في موضوع في السياسه الخارجيه
لكن ايضا هناك احترام لكن هناك اعتقد في
ملف الان
اعتقد ان اهم الملفات هو الملف اليمن ملف
اليمن الان احنا نعلم ان في لجنه رباعيه
وايضا منها بريطانيا والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه
واعتقد ان هذا الملف ملف مهم جدا على هذا
الملف سيد زيد في هذا الحوار ابقى معي اذا
مشاهدينا كما
اتهمس في مقابلاته الخاصه مع العربيه تم
ايران بزعزعه الاستقرار في المنطقه مؤكدا
ان كافه الخيارات مطروحه للتعامل مع طهران
وحذر ان امتلاك ايران لسلاح سيكون مبعث
قلق عالميه
اعتقد ان هناك خيارات كثيره لا احد يستبعد
اي خيار على الطاوله لكن لا اعتقد انه امر
جيد سيكون سيئا للغايه بالنسبه للمنطقه
لانه سيطلق العنان لسباق تسلح النووي
ونعتقد ان السلوك الايراني في الوقت
الراهن سلوك لا يتحلى بالمسؤوليه ويتسبب
بزعزعه الاستقرار على وتن على انه سلوك
عدواني سواء تعلق الامر بالعراق او اليمن
او تجاه السعوديه وسيثبت بان نظاما يمتلك
سلاح نووي سيكون خطيرا للغايه ومبعثا
للقلق البالغ بالنسبه لنا جميعا لذلك تصور
ان المجتمع الدولي يشعر بقلق بالغ لانه
بذر جهودا كبيره للتواصل لخطه العمل
الشامله المشتركه وهي معاهده اتفقنا عليها
جميعا قبل سنوات ما يجب القيام به محاوله
العوده الى ذلك الوضع
الوزير البريطانيه اضافه للعربيه بان
الشحنه الاسلحه الايرانيه المتطوره التي
تم ضبطها في المياه الدوليه جنوب ايران
تمثل خرقا لقرارات الامم المتحده مؤكدا
بان الحرس الثوري الايراني له صله بهذه
الشحنات
كان القارب يتواجد على بعد اميال جنوب غرب
ايران وقامت باعتراضه سفينه
التابعه للبحريه الملكيه البريطانيه خلال
عمليه تفتيش القارب اكتشفت على متنه شحنه
من الاسلحه المتنوعه تشمل اسلحه مضاده
للدبابات وكذلك مكونات محتمله لصواريخ
باليسيه هذا امر يثير قلقنا البالغ لانه
خرق للحظر المفروض من قبل الامم المتحده
وقد تم مصادره الاسلحه التي سنقوم بفحصها
من اجل معرفه وجهتها ومصدرها في عام 2022
اعترضت السفينه اتش ام اس قريبين كان
يقومان بتهريب الاسلحه التي اكتشفنا انها
لم تكن تضم مكونات الاسلحه البالسيه
واسلحه مضاده للدبابات فحسب وانما ايضا
تضمنت محركات لصواريخ كروز مصدرها ايران
كانت للحرس الثوري صله بها وهذا طبعا
يعتبر خرقا للحظر الذي تفرضه الامم
المتحده
هذا امر يثير قلقا بالغا لان طلوع ايران
في الاحداث الجاريه في اليمن يزعزع
الاستقرار ولا مصلحه لاي طرف فيه فهو لا
يفيد الحوثيين وبالتاكيد لا يفيد اي طرف
لكنه يمثل ايضا تهديدا للامن والاستقرار
في العالم انتم هنا في السعوديه لكم بعض
من هذه الدخائر وهم يقولون ان من اطلقها
الحوثيون لكن الشخص الذي يسلح الحوثيين
يتحمل ذاك المسؤوليه اعود مره اخرى الى
ضيفي زيد بن كمي مساعد رئيس تحرير الشرق
الاوسط مرحبا بك معي مره اخرى الوزير
البريطاني تحدث عن شحنه الاسلحه الايرانيه
التي تم فيها الحرس الثوري الايراني بانه
هو من كان طبعا وراء هذه العمليه ومحاوله
نقل هذه الاسلحه ربما الى الحوثينه في
اليمن اسال هنا عن الدوله البريطاني اليوم
في حل هذه الازمه اليمنيه كيف تقرا هل
يمكن ان يكون هناك
يعني محل ترعه بريطاني في هذه الازمه
اليمنيه الراهنه ام سنستمر في مزيد من
الصراع مزيد من التاجيج في ضوء ما قاله
بين ولس
البريطانيا هي دوله فاعله في الملف اليمني
وهي تسمى صاحبه القلم او حامله القلم فيما
يخص ايضا في القرارات العموميه او تقديم
القرارات المجلس الامن المتحده فيما يخص
الملف اليمني وهي تدعم ايضا
مثلا حل يعني الازمه في اليمن يعني هي
تشارك حتى يعني المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والبريطانيا متفقين على ضروره حل الازمه
بين اليمنيين انفسهم وهي الدوله كذلك ان
التدخل الايراني والدخول الايراني هو
مزعزع لامن واستقرار المنطقه وايضا في فصل
الملف في اليمن وايضا التدخل الايراني ليس
لحل القضيه باليمن بل هو يعني زياده اشعار
يعني تغير الموقف تجاه ايران فيما يخص هذه
الاسلحه فيما يخص الزوارق التي ضبطت حتى
فيما يخص البرنامج النووي الايراني
وتدخلات حتى ايران في دول المنطقه هل يمكن
ان تنعكس
وجهه النظر البريطانيه والتغير في الموقف
البريطاني على حلحله الازمه في اليمن ام
انها ستتعامل مع كل موضوع على حده
يعني انا في تحديد الملف اليمني انا يعني
البريطانيا هي فاعل دوله فاعله في الملف
اليمني لكن احنا نتامل يعني يكون ايضا
فيها دور اكبر والضغط ايضا على الجانب
الحوثي اللي للوصول الى حل هذه الازمه
التي طالت لها سنوات طويله بين اليمني
لذلك البريطانيا هي عظم مجلس الامن ودوله
فاعله في المجتمع الدولي وايضا هي ايضا في
الملف اليمني تحديدا فلذلك الوجود
البريطانيا والفاعليه الدوري البريطاني
مهم جدا لحل الملف اليمني لكن في المقابل
فيما يخص الملف الايراني طب الملف
الايراني جزء من ايضا هو تدخل في الشان
اليمني
وايران متدخله في كثير من الشؤون الدول
المنطقه وايضا هي الدوله يعني مزعزعه من
الاستقرار منطقه هي تصدر الاسلحه
لكل المنطقه نجدها في العراق في سوريا في
لبنان وايضا في اليمن لكن لو احنا ناخذ
قضيه اليمن لوحدها صحيحه ان الايران هي
دوله يعني
ليست حل الازمه اللي هي تزيد الازمه سوا
لذلك حينما تحدث الوزير عن الدور الايراني
هو لابد ان ايقاف الدور الايراني في الملف
اليمني اشكرك جزيل الشكر من لندن مساعد
رئيس تحرير الشرق الاوسط الصحه في زيد بن
كمي
في الرابعه ايضا ولكن بعد قليل
الاعلان عن استثمارات باكثر من 190 مليار
ريال ضمن برنامج تعزيز الشراكه مع القطاع
الخاص
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد اعلنت هيئه الاحصاء
السعوديه عن ارتفاع الصادرات السلعيه في
البلاد خلال الربع الرابع من العام الماضي
حيث بلغ اجمالي وصادرات التجاره الدوليه
الى اكثر من 342 مليار ريال فيما جاء
اجمالي الواردات من المنافذ السعوديه الى
193 مليار كما اكدت الهيئه على ان حجم
التجاره الدوليه خلال اداه الفتره بلغ
اكثر من 535 مليار ريال اما الميزان
التجاري وهو الفرق بين قيمه الصادرات
الواردات في السعوديه بلغ نحو 150 مليار
ريال وجاء الدول الصين والهند من اكثر
الدول الشريكه للسعوديه في الصادرات
والواردات وفق بيانات هيئه الاحصاء
السعودي
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره العدل السعوديه عن اقامه
المؤتمر العدلي الدولي بمدينه الرياض وذلك
في الخامس من الشهر الميلادي الجاري لمده
يومين المؤتمر العدلي الدولي سيجمع اكثر
من 50 متحدثا من الخبراء الدوليين في
القانون من مختلف دول العالم وبمشاركه ما
يتجاوز 4000 مشارك كما سينظم 15 جلسه نقاش
وورشه عمل لبحث سبل زياده الوعي بامكانات
التحول الرقمي والذكاء الاصطناعي في مجال
العداله
من الرياض ينضم الينا هاتفيا نائب وزير
العدل الدكتور نجم الزيد ما عليك اهلا
وسهلا فيك معنا في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
بدايه ما الذي يركز عليه هذا المؤتمر
الهدف كذلك ايضا حتى من اقامته في الرياض
اهلا وسهلا وشكرا جزيلا مثل ما تفضلت
الحقيقه احنا سعداء بالعقاب المؤتمر لحد
الدولي باذن الله في الرياضه اليوم الاحد
القادم
والمؤتمر ياتي في سياق ما يشهد العالم
لتطورات كبيره ومتسارعه في جميع القطاعات
وعلى وجه الخصوص
ما يخص توظيف التقنيه كوسيله متطوره
ومسانده للعداله ومعززه الحمل القضائي
احنا سعداء انه المؤتمر سيجمع باذن الله
تعالى نخبه من قيادات العدليه والقانونيه
المتخصصين حول العالم بتبادل المعرفه
والخبرات العقليه والاتراء القانوني باذن
الله تعالى
تركيز المؤتمر سيكون على وجه الخصوص
لمناقشه مستقبل التقنيات القضائيه والتحول
الرقمي في المجال العدلي وايضا التعاون
الدولي في المجال العدلي وكذلك تنفيذ
الاحكام الاجنبيه واحكام التحكيم
ضمن اتفاقيات التعاون القضائي والقانون
الدولي
فاذا مناقشه افاق استثمار تقنيات الذكاء
الاصطناعي في تطوير العمل القضائي
والتجارب الدوليه في هذا المجال وموافقه
التشريعات الداخليه الاتفاقيات التعاون
القضائي باذن الله تعالى المؤتمر هو
نؤيسر الوصول للعداله بتقنيات رقميه وزاره
العدل السعوديه من الوزارات التي يعني
طورت كثيرا من الخدمات الرقميه التقنيات
ايضا كذلك العدليه ما هي التجربه التي
ستنقلها وزاره العدل
وتتشارك فيها مع كل يعني القادمين الى هذا
المؤتمر في الرياض من مختلف دول العالم
التي ستشارك في هذا المؤتمر معاليك
الكل يعرف ان المملكه اليوم ولله الحمد
تعمل في اطار رؤيه 2030 اللي تحظى بدعم
وتوجيه كريم من القياده الرشيده والرؤيه
يعني تنضوي
وتطورات غير مسبوقه في كافه القطاعات
من ضمنها ما يتعلق بالبنيه التحتيه
الرقميه
وبناء على هذا التطور نشهد حقيقه التحولات
غير مسبوقه في القطاع العديد ولعلي اركز
على جانبين في هذا المجال المجال الاول ما
يتعلق بتطوير منظومه التشريعات المتخصصه
ورفعت ورفع كفاءه البنيه التشريعيه
الموجوده في المملكه وشهدنا مؤخرا
برعايه كريمه من ايضا القياده الرشيده
اصدار عدد من التشريعات لاول مره تفطر في
في تاريخ المملكه اذا سمحت بالاضافه الى
ما يتعلق برفع جوده الحياه في المتالق
بالخدمات الرقميه العادليه الموجوده اليوم
اليوم لدينا تحول رقمي يصل الى نسبه مئه
بالمئه من خدمات القضاء والتوثيق والتنفيذ
والمصالحه
واكثر من 150 خدمه الكترونيه اليوم مقدمه
الحمد هي ليست فقط الى تيسير جوده الحياه
وانما حتى رفع مستوى الالتزام والشفافيه
ان شاء الله دكتور أنا شكر لك وجودك معنا
اليوم في نشره الرابعه هاتفيا من الرياض
نائب وزير العدل الدكتور نجم الزايد شكرا
جزيلا لك
اعلنت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين عن خطه
التشغيليه لموسمي رمضان والتي تضمنت تهيئه
المداخل والمخارج بكامل طاقتها
الاستيعابيه بما فيها التوسعه السعوديه
الثالثه كما خصصت ايضا متاحف ثابته
ومتنقله بالاضافه الى ابواب مخصصه لكبار
السن وذوي الاعاقه الرئاسه اشارت كذلك الى
نطاق الاستيعابيه للمسجد الحرام تصل الى
ثلاثه ملايين زائر ومعتمر كما اتاحت
الترجمه من والى 51 لغه من حول العالم
من الحرم المكي ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
سلطان السلمي سلطان مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض ماذا لديك من معلومات
حول هذه الخطه التشغيليه لموسم رمضان التي
اعلنت عنها برئاسه شؤون الحرمين
اهلا بك نايف واهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه من داخل الصحن المطاف اذا بدات مع
ملامح الاستحام الكبيره الذي يشهده الحرم
المكي منذ بدايه الشهر شعبان اذ اعلنت
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين ان من المتوقع استقبال
اعداد مليونيه في موسم رمضان هذا العام
لذلك عملت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين برفقه
قطاعات الامنيه والجهات الخدميه العامله
هنا في الحرم المكي بوضع خطه تشغيليه
كبيره جدا للتعامل مع كافه الاعداد
المتوقعه خلال موسم رمضان هذا العام نتحدث
ان الحرم المكي يستوعب ثلاثه مليون مؤتمر
ومصلي في اليوم الواحد ولكن اريد ان اخذكم
في بعض التفاصيل او الارقام المتعلقه
بالحرم المكي والخطه التشغيليه هذا العام
تتحدثنا على صحن المطاف والادوار العلويه
نتحدث على مئه وسبعه الاف مؤتمر يستوعبه
صحن المطاف خلال الساعه الواحده نتحدث على
قرابه 12 الف موظف سوف يعملون في موسم هذا
العام لخدمه المعتمرين والمصلين ايضا
نتحدث انه تم فتح كافه المصليات والتوسعات
السعوديه الثلاثه هنا في الحرم المكي
للتعامل مع كافه الاعداد المتوقعه الكبيره
في موسم هذا العام ايضا يتحدث على تم
تخصيص عشره الاف عربه تعمل خلال الساعه
الواحده هنا في الحرم المكي كذلك نتحدث
على 100 طبيب وطبيب يعملون في اماكن
الاعتكاف وكذلك 2500 تصريح سوف يتم
تخصيصها هذا العام
للمعتمرين في داخل المسجد الحرام ايضا
فيما يتعلق بان نتحدث على خدمات التقنيه
والخدمات الالكترونيه اكثر من 14 موقع
وتطبيق هنا في الحرم المكي منها سبعه
تطبيقات ذكيه 51 لغه سوف يتحدثون بها
مترجمين المسجد الحرام والقطاعات العامله
هنا كذلك نتحدث على عشر خطب سوف تكون
يوميه في المسجد الحرام كذلك ثلاثه
روبوتات ايضا نتحدث على اكثر من عشرين الف
نقطه شرب للمياه كذلك وجود عدد كبير من
المرشدين وكذلك المفتيل لاعطاء النصائح
والتوجيهات الدعويه لكافه المعتمرين
والمصلين في المسجد الحرام ايضا نتحدث على
14 باب للدخول وكذلك 15 باب تم تهيئته
لخروج المصلين كذلك فيما يتعلق بالمنطقه
الخارجيه من الحرم المكي اذا تحدثنا على
تهيات
وتسهيل خمسه مسارات من ضمنها سوف تكون
اليك مسارات
للمشاه لوصول المعتمرين في اوقات الذروه
وتحديدا في صلاه التراويح وحتى في ايام
العشر الاواخر من خلال دخولهم وايقاف
المطابخ ودخول المعتمرين والمصلين الى
الحرم المكي تنتهيت اربعه مسارات رئيسيه
وكذلك فيما يتعلق بالقطاعات الامنيه تم
وضع نقاط فرز لتسهيل عمليات الدخول وفك
ازدحامات بشكل ملحوظ نعم سلطان اشكرك جزيل
الشكر لم يتبقى لدي الكثير من الوقت من
الحرم المكي مراسل العربيه سلطان السلميه
شكرا جزيلا لك
شركات وثيقه جمعت رابطه العالم الاسلامي
بمنظمات امميه منها منظمه الامم المتحده
للطفوله اليونيسف بهدف دعمي ومسانده
الفئات الاكثر ضعفا خصوصا الاطفال في
المجتمعات الفقيره الذين يعانون ازمات
منها اللجوء والنزوح حول العالم نتابع
بعضا من برامج الرابطه مع اليونيسف
اهداف المشتركه جمعت رابطه العالم
الاسلامي بمنظمات امميه اثمرت عن عقد
شراكات لتنفيذ برامج في دول يعاني سكانها
من مشاكل منها الفقر والنزوح والحروب ابرز
هذه الشراكات تنفيذ الرابطه برامجه تنمويه
مشتركه مع منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله
اليونيسيف في دول مختلفه خلال السنوات
الاخيره لتخفيف معاناه الاطفال سواء كانوا
لاجئين او ناجحين او من متضرري الحروب
والكوارث البرامج المشتركه بين الرابطه
واليونيسف هدفت في مجملها الى تعزيز وصول
الاطفال الى المدارس وضمان استمراريتهم في
الدراسه ومعالجه سوء التغذيه في بعض
المناطق اضافه الى تمكينهم من الحصول على
الخدمات الاجتماعيه الاساسيه الجيده عبر
تقديم الدعم النفسي والاجتماعي فضلا عن
تنفيذ برامج تطعيم ضد امراض منها شلل
الاطفال وفيروس كورونا وغيره
شراكه مع مفوضيه الامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين بهدف توفير الدعم الانساني
للاجئين ومحاوله دمجهم في مجتمعاتهم
الجديده حيث عقدت اتفاقيه لدعم الاف
اللاجئين وطالبي اللجوء في اليونان لضمان
حصولهم على الخدمات الاساسيه وتاهيلهم
للاندماج والمضي قدما في بناء حياه جديده
نجحت مجموعه روشن للتطوير العقاري احد
مشاريع صندوق الاستثمارات العامه في
السعوديه بتسليم اكثر من 30% من الوحدات
السكنيه الخاصه بالمرحله الاولى في مشروع
سدره السكني شمال العاصمه الرياض وذلك بعد
بدءها بتسليم الوحدات السكنيه للملاك في
شهر نوفمبر الماضي قبل الموعد المحدد
بعامين ويعد حي سدره اول مجتمع سكني ضخم
ينفذ في السعوديه يستهدف تنفيذه اكثر من
ثلاثين الف وحده سكنيه
انضم الينا من حيث سدره التابعه لمشروع
روشن في الرياض مراسل العربيه عبد الواحد
الحميد عبد الواحد مساء الخير حياك الله
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض وكلمني
اكثر عن هذا المشروع مشروع سدره كذلك ايضا
اذا كان هناك من معلومات حول عدد الوحدات
التي تم تسليمها في هذا المشروع
اهلا وسهلا بك نايف نعم طبعا اقف الان في
منتصف مشروع سدره يعني الذي بدات ملامحه
بالظهور تدريجيا نشاهد العديد من الوحدات
السكنيه الجاهزه التي بعضها حتى يعني قد
تم استلامها من قبل الملاك كما اعلنت
مجموعه روشن هناك طبعا 30% من المرحله
الاولى تم تسليمها قبل موعد بعامين هذا
المشروع وهذا المجتمع كما تسميه المجموعه
هو يحتوي العديد من
المحاور الرئيسيه نتحدث عن الحدائق
والمراكز الصحيه اضافه الى يعني حتى
الممرات وطبعا الاماكن التي يتم فيها خدمه
السكان المحليين نريد ان نتعرف اكثر نايف
على كل هذه التفاصيل ينضم الينا خالد
الدغيثر وهو المتحدث الرسمي لمجموعه روشن
اهلا وسهلا بك خالد اولا نريد ان نسال كيف
استطعتم انجاز طبعا وتسليم هذه الوحدات
قبل الموعد بسنتين ممتاز حياكم الله اول
شيء في حي سدره طبعا احنا في مجموعه روشن
نحرص على الالتزام بوعودنا وبالنسبه
لتسليم الوحدات قبل الوقت المحدد الحمد
لله هذا تم بسبب وضع او وضع كان هناك
دراسات عديده ووضع او بناء الدليل العام
القايد لاين اللي من خلاله عملنا مع
شركائنا المطورين العقاريين او في في
الرياض تحديدا سهل علينا التعاون معهم
فبالتالي كانت كان في سهوله في في بناء
الخطط وتحديد المواعيد للتنفيذ يعني بشكل
واضح وما ننسى طبعا الدعم اللي يعني
تحصلوا روشه من مجلس ادارتها وكذلك من
صندوق استثمارات العامه بالتاكيد هذا
الشيء طبعا سرع في عمليه التنفيذ مع
الحفاظ على الجوده بالتاكيد طيب بالنسبه
للمرحله الاولى ما المقصود بالمرحله
الاولى
حي صدره يتكون من ثمان مراحل على مساحه 20
مليون متر مربع
يحتوي على اكثر من 30 الف وحده سكنيه طبعا
بانواع مختلفه
المرحله الاولى طبعا هي تنبعها بالكامل
وبدات التسليم فيها اللي تو حكينا فيه
هي طبعا يعني كمرحله الاولى مجتمع سدره
بشكل عام هو يقع في
على طريق المطار امام جامعه الاميره نوره
تقريبا هو واجهه اللي موجوده على الطريق
مثل ما ذكرت مساحته كبيره
شمالا وجنوبا
من مميزاته طبعا وجود المسطحات الخضراء
بنسب عاليه
المساجد المدارس المراكز التموين او البيع
بالتجزئه الملاعب الرياضيه بكل انواعها
كذلك مثل ما تفضلت انت قبل شوي اللي هو
وجود الممرات المشي وكذلك مرات ركوب
الدراجات وهذا السبب اللي يعني
يخلي روشن او يخلينا في روشن ما نسميه
مجمع سكنين نسميه مجتمع طبعا برضه اذا
بحكي عن مميزاتها عبد الواحد هي طبعا
بيوتنا يعني ما فيها اسوار اماميه وفيها
اماكن للمشاركه او زي المجالس بالعاميه
يجتمعون فيها اهل الحي بدل ما يكون اجتماع
في داخل بيوتهم شكرا جزيلا لك خالد غيثر
المتحدث الرسمي لمجموعه روشن على كل هذه
التفاصيل كما شاهدت نايف طبعا يتم التسليم
حسب الخطه وحسب الجداول التي تضع ها
مجموعه روشن للملاك اولا باول شكرا جزيلا
لك من حي سدره التابع لمشروع روشن في
الرياض مراسل العربي عبد الحميد ولضيفك
الكريم
اعلن برنامج تعزيز الشراكه مع القطاع
الخاص في السعوديه عن الحزمه الاولى من
مشاريع الشركات الكبرى المنضمه الى
البرنامج المصمم خصيصا لدعم الشركات
السعوديه الكبرى والتي بلغت قيمتها اكثر
من
1992 مليار ريال تفاصيل الحزمه الاولى مع
زميله العنود العبدلي
قام برنامج تعزيز الشراكه مع القطاع الخاص
في السعوديه شريك الحزمه الاولى من
مشاريعه بقيمه
192 مليارا و400 مليون ريال وذلك ضمن
مساعيه لزياده الاستثمارات المحليه لشركات
القطاع الخاص لتصل الى خمسه تريلونات ريال
سعودي بحلول عام 20 30 12 مشروعا تابعا
لثماني شركات شهدتها الحزمه من البرنامج
وذلك في عدد من القطاعات الاستراتيجيه
والحيويه وتمثل حصه شركات الكبرى من
الحزمه الاولى 120 مليارا ريال اما عن عدد
الوظائف التي سيتحدثها برنامج شريك خلال
هذه المرحله مشاهدينا فتصل الى اكثر من 64
الف وظيفه وسيقدم البرنامج الدعم لخمسه
مشاريع خاصه بشركه ارامكو وذلك لاستحداث
اكثر من عشره الاف وظيفه من ضمن هذه
المشاريع مشاهدينا الخمسه مشروع خدمات
الحوسبه السحابيه التي توفر خدمات جوجل
السحابيه في السعوديه وفي قطاع الطاقه
ايضا مشاهدينا برنامج شريك سيقدم دعما
لشركه اكوا باور لانشاء اكبر مصنع لانتاج
الهيدروجين الاخضر في العالم اما في قطاع
البتروكاميون كيماويات مشاهدينا فشركه
سابك حصلت على دعم برنامج شريك لانشاء اول
مركز لصناعه المحفزات في السعوديه بهدف
تقليل الاعتماد على الواردات وتعزيز
الصادرات اما في قطاع الاتصالات مشاهدينا
في برنامج شريك قام بدعم شركه اس تي سي
لتنفيذ مشروع كابلات بحريه في خطوه
استراتيجيه ستعزز مكانه السعوديه بوصفها
مركزا رقميا ووجهه موثوقه لحركه البيانات
كما قدم البرنامج ايضا مشاهدينا دعمه
لشركه الاتصالات المتنقله زين وذلك لتنفيذ
مشروع انشاء مراك ز بيانات رقميه وذلك
بهدف المساهمه في تحويل اقتصاد السعوديه
الى اقتصاد رقمي رائد واخيرا قطاع النقل
والخدمات اللوجستيه سيدعم برنامج شريك
مشاهدينا شركه البحر السعوديه لتوفير
خدمات نقل الامونيا لاول مره في السعوديه
الذي يقلل الاعتماد على الناقلات الاجنبيه
عبر تعزيز المحتوى المحلي في قطاع الخدمات
اللوجستيه
اعلنت وزاره البيئه والمياه والزراعه
السعوديه عن تسجيل متوسط هطول الامطار
خلال شهر يناير الماضي مستوى قياسيا بلغ
اكثر من 23 مليمتر وهو الاعلى منذ اربعين
عاما اوضح المركز انه تم تسجيل اعلى عدد
قراءات مطريه في يوم واحد فالث من يناير
وبلغ 249 قراءه فيما سجلت محطه ميناء جده
اعلى قراءه مطريه بلغت اكثر من 84 مليمتر
في الاول من يناير الماضي
وقعت الهيئه الملكيه لمحافظه العلا شمال
غرب السعوديه مرصد مناره العلا والذي من
المتوقع ان يكون معلما جديدا يقصده الزوار
من جميع انحاء العالم يسهم المرصد الجديد
بتوفير البناء التحتيه اللازمه للابحاث
والكوادر في مجال الفضاء وتعزيز حضور
العلا كوجهه عالميه في علوم الفضاء والفلك
بالاضافه الى خلق قيمه اقتصاديه في البحث
والتطوير والابتكار
انطلق صاروخ فالكون تسعه والذي يحمل على
متنه رائد الفضاء الاماراتي سلطان النيادي
الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه حيث من المقرر ان
تستمر الرحله التي تعد اطول مهمه عربيه في
الفضاء لمده سته اشهر
نحن الان على عتبات موسم السرايات والمسمى
بامطار الصيف في التفاصيل في تقويم عقد
الزعاج
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عندنا امطار شتاء وامطار صيف الشتويه تسبق
بامطار الهريف في شهر اغسطس والصيفيه تسبق
بامطار سبق السرايات في شهر مارس والهريف
والسبق هي امطار ممهده لها والهريف تتركز
على المناطق الجنوبيه واليمن وسلطنه عمان
والسرايات تتركز على اداء من الحجاز ونجد
والمنطقه الشرقيه والكويت ونحن الان على
عتبات موسم السرايات المسمى بامطار الصيف
وهي امطار متفرقه تكون في بقعه دون ثانيه
ومشوبه بحبات برد ولها صوت دبدبه وحبت
المطر كبيره ولاليه التهاطل لا تسال
الليله عن دمعي وعن وجعي ايسكونان وطيف
الراحلين معي ادري بهم رحلوا ما عاد لي
امل عقلي وعى غير ان القلب ليس
يعي
[موسيقى]
والامطار الشتويه تنبت الربيع الشتوي وهو
نبت ناعم مثل الروض والنفل والامطار
الصيفيه تنبت الربيع الصيفي وهو شجر خشن
مثل الحمض وهنا الاولين الله يرحمهم
يهتمون بالربيع الصيفي اكثر من الشتوي ليش
لانه يرعون به الحولي كامل اي سنتين كامله
ولهذا قالوا يا الله بصيفيه المرعى بها
حوليه ولا شتويه بها وسميه
[موسيقى]
في تغطيه خاصه تبدا من العاشره صباحا
بتوقيت السعوديه السابع بتوقيت جرينتش
تحتفل العربيه بالذكرى لعشرين لانطلاقتها
في الثالث من مارس عام 2003 باقه متنوعه
من النشرات ستتابعونها غدا مشاهدينا
ختام الرابعه وهذه ابرز عناوينهم
مجموعه اباجنر الروسيه تنشر صورا لافرادها
تقول انها سجلت من داخل مدينه بخموت
وزير الدفاع البريطاني يؤكد في لقاء مع
العربيه على قوه وعنقي علاقه بلاده مع
الرياض
وزير خارجيه السعوديه يدعو الى حل صراعته
والنزاعات الدوليه لمواجهه التحديات
العالميه
مجموعه روشن تسلم اكثر من 30% من وحدات
المرحله الاولى لمشروعها
السكني الشمال الرياض شكرا لكم على كرمي
ولطف المتابعه دائما العربي لمزيد من
الاخبار والمعلومات نهايه الرابعه نلقاكم
غدا الزميل خالد مدخلي الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]